this is a it's a real [ __ ] hey what's
going on everybody four first we feast
I'm Sean Evans and you're watching hot
one it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings today I'm joined by
Thomas Middleditch you know him as
Richard Hendricks in the hit
award-winning HBO series Silicon Valley
now in its fourth season and speaking of
you catch new episodes on Sunday 10:00
p.m. Eastern on HBO Thomas welcome to
the show
hi thank you so much for having me how
are you with hot food I'm medium with
hot food sometimes I like to spit a
spice most times I don't mind a little
bit in fact speak it but I've never been
one to call myself the master of spice
well today or like be the master of
spice the king of spice even oh yeah
yeah yeah I'm ready
[Music]
is it a bad sign when the Gus is like
mmm that's great I made the whole thing
got a great start you like it yeah best
miner
Falacci who hadn't had that probably a
couple people losers [ __ ] [ __ ] so
my guess is that your more casual fans
probably think that your comedy career
started in Silicon Valley but the day
one people know that it's been a 15 year
long grind my god you didn't even add a
couple more years on there if we camp my
stint in regional theater I know that a
lot of the people on Second City they
earned their stripes on the cruise ship
circuit did you do the cruise ship I
certainly did it was a four months then
2 months roughly we poured out of New
York and we went like Bahamas Bermuda
summer vacation stuff a lot of like
working-class Bronx Jersey Queens and
that my first Quito's with the haircut
it's Oh second city let me buy a shot oh
my god oh my gosh you want us and all
you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you know like
that kind of stuff
like and then like de Barras and it's
like he like teens getting caught like
fingering each other I'm very much a
rite of passage I was just like oh my
goodness and then we stopped for the
fall tour to watch the leaves change who
into like Boston Bar Harbor Maine
Newfoundland Quebec City no one under 50
they played Andrews Sisters on PA
everyone was in bed by like 9:00 p.m.
and then the crew would just have like
the ship to himself I love that I can
ask my god the scenery you know some
people they poopoo to that go mm-hmm
because it's got a bit of like a vinegar
taster and I like that I like that I
like that that's what turn some people
off yeah that's what I like I think that
by virtue of your role that you've
probably had some contact with the tech
world do you find that it's more or less
insufferable than the version that you
guys portray on the show I mean look mmm
oh I don't want to throw you know the
people who like the show under the bus
I'll say this most of the time where
I've met like actual developers and
programmers it's been usually a pleasant
experience
I have met some VC venture capitalist
who have been less pleasant it's like
your time with them is something that
they own and it's like goddamn right
you'll you'll spend 20 minutes while I
tell you how much the show I've lived
you know that kind of stuff what if I
surprise myself
is it around this time where people get
you know like confidence and like I
think I can do this and then there's a
sobering realization around here where
they want to bring a gun and shoot their
brains out on the internet I have seen
that happen countless times you know
I've used this analogy before it kind of
like a professional wrestler when a
wrestler cockiest
you know we're talking my language is
downfall like that's when he gets a
chair smashed over his back okay well I
know it all into that trap I want to
talk to you about geekery for a second
because in addition don't know anything
about it he means your dog after Harry
Potter Chris you all sir no stranger to
the Renaissance Fair yes how in do it do
you get you go in character you talk
with an accent I don't go in character
that would be [ __ ] annoying and I
can't stand meeting those people um I
have garb though I have a hands-on
costume yeah it's like going to
Halloween and not dressing up you know
like that you're not really doing it
right and then what's this scene like
there because you know there's always
these stories about how there's kind of
like a psychedelic or like shrooms sort
of subculture that's what I wanted to
believe I was like hey I'll go I'll stay
late next thing you know I'll be invited
to an orgy by the firelight but like
frumpy weird sort of like S&M fan women
what about as a single scene like if you
were single do you think that that would
be a good place to meet people are not a
good place to meet people be a good
place to meet a certain type of people
if you're a little bit chilled up and
realize a place like that is an
opportunity to cut your wings yeah who
you are yeah the renters it's just
mainly to be like I want to go and be a
fairy or a barmaid or something and just
be weird
so this one is the Queen Majesty Oh a
nod to my British Ruth so I wouldn't be
doing my job at first we'd be if we
didn't unpackage this rap that you made
making fun of McDonald's that somehow
someway became an actual commercial
Chicken McNuggets
mm-hmm McDonald's was just starting it's
like urban campaign of like not us
that's not that like it's all like hey
like two guys playing basketball like
let's go Madonna like what I would
literally do Zuzu and I just thought it
was so transparently bandar-e I don't
rub me the wrong way so after like two
years of it being online
it got thought did that surprise you it
had to have been totally days you were
coming from a satirical place so to have
them actually acknowledge it and then
validate it is interesting yeah what was
weirder it is before it before
McDonald's bought it people who
advertisers who were writing a book on
viral marketing used it as an example so
it's in a book it's referenced also in
literature as well
[Music]
there's sweetness in there mm-hmm the
next part of the show is called explain
that Graham what we do is we do a deep
dive on our guests instagramming full
interesting pictures that need more
contact so I'll show you the picture and
then you just tell me the bigger stories
that sound radical yeah I love Graham
you're on this from my Graham yeah I'm
out of Twitter I deleted it gone I know
[ __ ] it it's too negative why did you
delete your Twitter it's me and
everything is mean on there it's just
noisy internationally and that's like
the amplification of the Internet's
noise so I always have that kind of that
thought like maybe I should just get rid
of everything and maybe I live a happier
life because there is so much messaging
from like so many different angles and
maybe that's kind of like you know
affecting my life and affecting my
happiness have you found so she deleted
Twitter does it feel a little bit
liberating
well you miss it at all well I first
deleted Facebook don't miss it all I
still sort of have that impulse feel
like I could say that but I everything
still mean yeah there it is the veget
it's courage to use some you know just
the ether why why subjection zone to it
just get off and then it suddenly goes
away it's great all right so this first
one got the falkland arms with Patrick
Stewart yeah peace do Patrick Stewart
has um
strangely become a very good friend I do
this show called The Improv a
Shakespeare Company also born home
Chicago yeah he has played with us from
time to time and just through that we've
become buddies and we have recent I
recently recently had a trip to old dear
old England and John that I have to say
it and then we made it made a side trip
to the cost walls even though that's not
that at all and he's got a place out
there and then I was kind of split
between this Patrick Stewart picture but
there was like another one where it
looked like you were playing Monopoly
and Reggie Watts is there was like a
whole that was yeah that was like a
wonderful motley crew dinner type of
thing yes and we did play Monopoly and
guess who won that Thomas [ __ ] right
I beat everybody I mean all those
Hollywood [ __ ] rudeboys on the ladder
it's all exquisitely like on brand
dorkiness a couple of the guys that
we should get jackets because we're a
gang what color says the rudeboys yeah
we was on the lot Sony Pictures Bond
okay cool and we found a website that
you could order custom jackets and they
even have like dice on the back Wow yeah
and then so we thought okay we're the
room boys you know we don't give it here
at knowing like knowing who we are or
like yeah we're rude and we took our
scooters and we wanted to like scoot
around a lot with our jackets we did
this ride and like two minutes into it a
security officers like hey you can only
ride bicycles here you can't use those
more like oh we're sorry turned around
and just put them away blood in blood
out when it comes to rude boys okay yeah
then we killed that guy afterwards we
hunted them down we shot so you've said
that on your offing mm-hmm you spend
hours playing video games not ours check
with the life it was literally our it
was all day yesterday for hours
yeah is the league of champs still a
thing Wow how do you know about the old
LOC what soldier I created a little
league and a playoffs tournament and it
kind of started growing and eventually
trophies we're Sen people got trophies
and stuff it was super fun
I am curious it spilled the beans you'll
twitch stream and you get all into it
with the headset and know if you have
any strange interactions with strangers
over that headset come on kind of a
volatile place it what I'm coming to
experience not only with twitch but like
social media it's like I'm not sure if
all this access is a good thing or at
least me reading the access because it's
like for every nine very positive people
there's one person it's just a prick and
he's probably 14 years old at but in the
world of anonymous nests
that's 40 year old like you're gay if
there or whatever is yes it like cuts
through him is like oh I was having such
a fun time I'm in the last comment
Estelle's plant which i look over this
being ghost so this is what being a
celebrity has been reduced to streaming
video games online for teenagers I was
like you're right
exit sorry guys I got a code quit shut
it down like he's right what am i doing
I'm trying to be an actor and I'm doing
this and it's so weird that it's a
little control really makes you real
value in your life I start smoking this
one mm-hmm
no I don't just like smokey but I do
like the tank what do you think the
zombie apocalypse I mean I like it it's
[ __ ] hot though mm-hmm it's a creeper
as well so for a lot of actors working
with Martin Scorsese is kind of the Holy
Grail I know that it was a relatively
small role in the movie Wall Street yeah
I had to audition quite heavily for that
first indie was interesting only in a
sense that like his ad I'm assuming it
was his assistant director what
ah he's everything do you think he is
teat is we he's happy answer like this
right okay yeah what you did there right
I don't know I hear like AHA you likes
it just do whatever you know like okay
that was it I was very short and sweet
you know I'm very much supporting in
that thing for Jonah in that boat I seen
he flicks the [ __ ] every was like new
issue day you [ __ ] clean you think I
knew I should get the [ __ ] outta here
was like gobo you suck and I knew a
couple people like Brian sacca and some
other people that were and they they got
they took it upon themselves to get
personal like you big nose break and
then extras were like yeah you pretty
[ __ ] bird trilling I'm like this is
terrible and that one I'm probably an
hour and a half two hours you know
you'll have to add the end of the day
after day it's just a movie they don't
really think that this looks like do to
love pot made this label it looks like
people are like oh now you dig some
black back in purple kush brow [ __ ]
Hawaii dank take some Barbie on a family
see you later
[Music]
I think they're going to have the last
laugh on that see it becomes like a
different type of spice mm-hmm oh yeah I
might not eat the whole thing of that
probably smart so now that your native
of British Columbian here at first we
feast we care way too much about what
people eat so I want to talk to you
about your love for ruffles all dressed
over here number one flavor in Canada
sure what do you love about ruffles all
dress well if you're better if you're
fan of death if you like best over heavy
flavors now there's people who like
chips who like heavy flavors you know
barbecue thank you one hitter you find a
lot of heavy flavors in American stores
I got to be honest very few reviews st-1
guys help
god help you if you try to take an
american away from a sour cream and
cheddar hmm what I like the debt I like
salt and vinegar
I like all dress you'd think that all
dressed it's like Lizette every flavor
on one ship no that would be disgusting
I'll just is like a vinegary zesty anime
and the fact that it's just now making
him down here is both great and awful I
mean there was for a second for a brief
second Canada had something that you
guys didn't we could hold on to it and
say you may have a big army and a big
Navy on the big Air Force
we have all just chips and Koo Kien all
right so this is mad dog 357 yeah mad
dog boobs done like a caliber madam I
got underneath my pillow just catch an
intruder comes out new I love that
you're going to happen what's good about
that
I like that taste better mm-hmm you know
the bomb has very few if any redeeming
quality has [ __ ] like Mad Dog at
least they're trying to make something
happen and that does at least give
another contact shot it's not nothing
you I feel and so far I'm pretty good I
feel confident I can make it so before I
get to my question first I want to say
congratulations on getting your pilot's
license was that kind of a hobby with
somebody on your eyes that on for a long
time or it's been it's been a dream for
one for a while
had I had any common sense
what's the reaction going on in here
now do I come back flips in there that's
like hey evacuate go you have to throw
up no no but why do i brief all the time
I've burp some pretty nice okay let's
get time what do you remember about your
first time flying that was scary but I
enjoyed it
wow that right mm-hmm here's the deal
[Music]
fight life has been a passion of mine
for about 15 years I got on my flight
simulators been into those for a long
time life came by way of a Miller
a passion for military history
start talking about military history
instruction of my fighter flight
I almost exclusively read fighter pilot
memoirs are you in the mile-high club
not yet this is someone's very prudish
all right Thomas
are you putting extra us it hurt
this is Blair's Megadeth sauce with
liquid rage is tradition around here to
put a little dab on the last wing you
don't think sorry only starting on there
you don't have to if you don't want to
something which you don't have to feel
want to you don't have to feel on you
Dom Dom comes through three what was the
pain usually end though mmm like how
long is this gonna happen huh I put a
dab on a mess look listen for the next
15 or 20 minutes as you put a dab on it
where you don't put a dab on xbox
I want your prices yes brain said no
good to it
[Music]
my dad might be okay look not a dick
measuring contest oh that's interesting
I've never seen this move before huh
kind of help no do we cheers Cheers
[Music]
- big amat okay all right what's the big
deal with this guy but his hominem
ingredients on the planet Earth please
use extreme caution so native a
decade-and-a-half sort of improv
experience I'm sure that many people
think that Thomas Middleditch is much
like his character Richard but most of
the characters that you've done over the
years like doobs and Joey tortellini
have their big personality characters as
well Felix you mean I'm hoping that
while the blares Megadeth sauce with
liquid rage is channeling through you
that you can summon one of those classic
characters to give the people out there
a yelp review on blares Megadeth sauce
with liquidly oh I kept my posters over
there like we should stop fine Rachel
[Music]
okay Lizabeth there's a real bad it was
joy totally like this right I'm gonna
tell you the only thing hotter than this
something this sauce on the page that I
DJ to every every night in Vegas I can't
remember all the details
it was a tough episode for not only you
but for me as well over here
major food quest Tommy doing backflips
tell me doing that flip but Johnny
Batman glanced over here you made it
through again you cleared the board
you're better man for it if I look into
your eyes that's right this camera this
camera this camera lets people know what
you have going on in your life I'll be
later on shooting bloody hell out of my
butthole we're on but other than that
you can check Silicon Valley season four
out and also Captain Underpants July and
at some point I'm gonna film with Keanu
Reeves and called replicas that should
be interesting
[Music]
your theory a little bit I'm no
superhero
I'm not super we're all that's not the
lyric I'm trying to do some Foo Fighter
I'm you're supposed to what is it
which one were you trying to do I don't
know superhero BAE but we're trying to
do the yeah yes I may be I could be over
here obey and that alarm and then maybe
I was also get get higher goes my hero
I'm doing the Foo Fighters and there's
also ye I yeah yeah yes Superman said
but who's got our Lady peace you're
really maybe they're Canadian it's hard
to tell now it is hey what's going on
hot ones fans if you liked the video
maybe meet us halfway throw us a
subscribe if you didn't like the video
don't subscribe I don't want you I don't
want you in the tent but if you like the
video subscribe thank you very much I
appreciate you I love you more than a
friend